woher kommen die menschen die sich auf
eine odyssee nach belarus begeben juli
man ja im nordirak von hier aus haben
sich viele aufgemacht ihr ziel
deutschland vorerst soll die route
abgeschnitten seien doch auch die bilder
der letzten wochen können sie hier kaum
abschrecken
menschen wie sie er ist 19 jahre alt und
wurde gerade erst aus griechenland
abgeschoben jetzt wartet er auf die
nächste chance
ich kann hier nicht leben ich habe
einfach keine existenz um hier zu
bleiben
sein drei jahre jüngerer freund sitzt
schon auf gepackten koffern er will nach
belarus
ich werde das nicht mit schleusern
machen ich werde mit ein paar freunden
aufbrechen sie kennen den weg
im straßenbild ist die werbung für die
reise nach belarus verschwunden wir
wollen wissen ob dieser und reisen noch
angeboten werden wie funktioniert das
geschäft wir drehen mit versteckter
kamera
noch vor kurzem wurden visa und flüge in
reisebüros vermittelt wir versuchen es
tickets für iraker nach belarus haben
wir nicht auch über jordanien iran und
türkei geht nichts mehr
beim nächsten reisebüro haben wir mehr
glück
visa kann ich besorgen aber die airlines
haben flüge für iraker und syrer
gestoppt wir sind zwei familien brauchen
visa was kostet das für jede person 1400
dollar für kinder auch für jeden
derselbe preis die visa lassen wir in
ankara ausstellen in vier tagen kann ich
ihnen das visum schicken es gilt 14 tage
wenn sie das jetzt kaufen ist es zwar
ein risiko andererseits wenn es wieder
losgeht können sie sofort reisen und
dann werden visa und flüge sicher wieder
teurer sein
wir treffen einen reisebüro betreiber
der unerkannt bleiben will uns aber
erklärt wie das geschäft funktioniert
wir beantragen ein elektronisches wieso
das läuft über das ministerium in minsk
wir haben einen geschäftspartner in
belarus und der organisiert die
reisegenehmigung
auf dem smartphone zeigt er uns den e
mail verkehr mit seinem geschäftspartner
in belarus
hunderte von visa-anträgen die anderen
reisebüro in minsk gingen der name oskar
tour
die touristenbüros haben enge
beziehungen zur russischen regierung
aufgebaut sie versorgen unsere bürger
mit visa und führen sie dann an die
grenze zu polen
belarus macht damit politik und greift
die europäische union an
diesen angriff beantwortet polen für die
europäische union an ihrer außengrenze
mit strikter abschottung
polens regierungschef morawski
inszeniert sich per videobotschaft als
verteidiger europas und in historischer
linie
wenn es in der geschichte darum ging
invasoren tyrannen und später
totalitären diktaturen entgegenzutreten
standen wir immer an der frontlinie
heute ist das angriffsziel polen morgen
wird es deutschland belgien frankreich
oder spanien sein
mit einem grenzzaun will polen europa
verteidigen und den soll brüssel
bezahlen
dort droht allein darüber schon das
kalkül des diktators von minsk
aufzugehen europa zu spalten
es ist für mich ganz klar und es
herrscht einigkeit zwischen parlament
und kommission dass es keine finanzielle
unterstützung gibt für stacheldraht und
mauern
dabei präsentiert sich europa längst
vielerorts mit stacheldraht
ungarn hat den anfang gemacht und
migranten abzuwehren und wurde dafür
zunächst gescholten
mittlerweile sind kroatien und bulgarien
dem beispiel gefolgt und europa schweigt
[Musik]
ja es ist in gewisser weise ein
schizophrenes verhältnis mit orvana
intensiv kritisiert und zugleich
irgendwie doch gewusst dass die grenze
auch die eigenen schließungs interessen
bedient und so könnte es auch mit einem
polnischen
grenze bauwerk sein
währenddessen geht für tausende menschen
das drama in belarus weiter einer von
ihnen hat uns aufnahmen aus einem
logistikzentrum geschickt es liegt etwa
einen kilometer von der grenze entfernt
und dient als provisorisches
flüchtlingslager per videoanruf
erreichen wir eine frau sie sei sie den
zuerst vor dem bsg flohen dann vor der
not im flüchtlingslager sie zeigt uns
ihre kaputten vom regen aufgeweichten
schuhe
wir möchten nicht in den irak zurück
lieber sterbe ich hier als wieder in den
irak zurückzukehren
es ist schlimm hier schau mal was hier
los ist alle sind draußen
aber im irak wäre es noch schlimmer wir
möchten dass unser problem gelöst wird
wir möchten nach deutschland
der tyrann von minsk der diese tragödie
bewusst herbeigeführt hat nimmt neben
europa jetzt deutschland direkt ins
visier
in seinem kampf um internationale
anerkennung
wir werden mit den migranten auf unsere
art umgehen so lange deutschland sie
nicht aufnimmt was bleibt uns anderes
übrig aber wir fordern dass deutschland
sie aufnimmt denn sie wollen dorthin und
haben familie und freunde dort
spaß und kratzt damit am bild von der
einigkeit der berliner ampelkoalition er
bei denen die frage nach einer
gemeinsamen asyl und migrationspolitik
fundamentale differenzen zutage bringt
das wäre falsch der erpressung durch
lukaschenko nachzugeben und deswegen
muss das eigentliche ziel seien durch
diplomatie und durch druck im richtigen
mischungsverhältnis dafür zu sorgen dass
die menschen über minsk zurückfliegen
können in ihre heimatländer und die
ersten flüge haben ja bereits
stattgefunden das ist ein ganz großes
missverständnis das gleiche an der
stelle mal aufgeklärt werden kann wir
haben eine genfer flüchtlingskonvention
das hat übrigens auch polen
unterschrieben und wir haben einen
grenzmanagement dass ein recht und
ordnung gebunden ist und das heißt wenn
jemand an unseren außengrenzen ist dann
muss formal der zugang auch zu asyl wenn
man das denn will
eröffnet sein wie aber umgehen mit der
polnischen regierung die migranten
gewaltsam an der grenze zurückdrängt mit
so genannten push back
wir müssen natürlich auch darauf
beharren dass die europäische union als
wertegemeinschaft und als
rechtsstaatliches verbund auch sich ein
rechnung deshalb dazu gehört dann
manchmal dass es keinen putsch text
geben darf der gewünschte
regierungspartner fdp wiederspricht fuß
becks das war ja das thema das man das
bei ländern macht wo krieg herrscht und
die menschen fliehen ins nachbarland
dass man die nicht in der
kriegssituation zurückschiebt ist
vollkommen klar dass wir jetzt hier an
der polnisch russischen grenze sehen ist
eine völlig andere lage ein paar hundert
vielleicht ein paar tausend
einwanderungswillige reichen um deutsche
koalitionäre und ganz europa
herauszufordern in ihrem
selbstverständnis
so zu an den grenzen ist europa sehr
liberal zum teil eben auch sehr brutal
bis zum extrem das eben auch menschen um
ihr leben kommen aber im inneren möchte
es gerne sozialliberales selbstbild
behalten und dass beides passt bislang
nicht besonders gut zusammen
zurück in den nordirak am flughafen
treffen wir menschen die kälte und
hunger getrotzt haben und doch keinen
einlass erhielten nach europa es ist
eine frage der zeit bis sie eine neue
route finden und sich wieder auf den weg
machen mit dem ziel von sicherheit und
der chance auf wohlstand mit dem
reiseziel zukunft